the function m is given in three
equivalent forms which form most quickly
reveals the y-intercept
so let's just remind ourselves
if i have a function the graph y is
equal to
m of x
and
these are all equivalent forms they tell
us that the function m is given in three
equivalent forms i should be able to
algebraically manipulate any one of
these to get any of the other ones
and so if i wanted to graph and y is
equal to m of x and let's say it looks
something like
this and i actually know it's a downward
opening parabola because i can look at
this form right over here and say hey
look the coefficient on the second
degree term here is a negative so it's
going to be a downward opening parabola
that's a messy drawing of it and so if
we're talking about the y-intercept
we're saying hey where does it intersect
the y-axis so what is the y-value when x
is equal to zero so it boils down to how
quickly can we evaluate m of zero what
is m of x when m is when x is equal to
zero so how quickly can you evaluate m
of zero
well in this top one i can substitute
zero for x and so it'll be negative two
times negative 3 times negative 9. so
it's not too hard to figure out but
there's going to be some calculation in
my head
similarly in the second choice for x
equals 0 i'm going to get negative 6
squared which is positive 36 times
negative 2 which is negative 72 and then
i have to add that to positive 18. i can
do that but it's a little bit of
computation
but here for this last one and this is
known as standard form if i say x equals
0 that term disappears that terms
disappears and i'm just left with m of
zero is equal to negative 54. so
standard form this is standard form
right over here was by far the easiest
so we know the y-intercept is 0 comma
negative 54.
now one rule of caution sometimes you
might look at what is called vertex form
and as we'll see this is the easiest one
where it is to identify the vertex but
when you see this little plus 18 hanging
out it looks a lot like this negative 54
that was hanging out it's like hey when
x equals zero maybe i can just cross
that out the same way that i cross these
terms out and be very very careful there
because if x equals zero this whole
thing does not equal zero when x is
equal to 0 as i just said you have
negative 6 squared which is 36 times
negative 2 this is equal to negative 72.
so m of 0 is definitely not 18. so be
very very very careful but we can see
that the best choice is this one
standard form not vertex form or
factored form
factors form as you can me as you can
imagine is very good for figuring out
the zeros
let's do another example
and actually this is this is the same m
of x but we're going to ask something
else so it's given in those same three
forms
which form most quickly reveals the
vertex well i just called this vertex
form before
but what's valuable about vertex form
is you can really say okay
this is going to be this is going to
achieve its vertex when this thing over
here is equal to 0. how do i know that
well once you get used to vertex form
it'll just become a bit of second nature
but if this is a downward opening
parabola
the vertex is when you hit that maximum
point
and as you can see here x minus 6
squared is always going to be
non-negative you multiply that times the
negative 2 it's always going to be
non-positive it's either going to be 0
or a negative value so this is always
going to take away from this 18.
and so if you want to find the vertex
the maximum point here it would be the x
value that makes this thing equal to 0
because because for any other x value
this thing is going to be negative it's
going to take away from that 18. and so
you can see by inspection well what x
value will make this equal to 0
well if x is equal to 6 6 minus six is
equal to zero zero squared is zero times
negative two is zero and so m of six is
equal to eighteen
so this lets us know very quickly that
the vertex is going to happen at x is
equal to six
and then the y value there or the m of 6
is going to be equal to 18.
you can do it with these other ones the
hardest one would be standard form
standard form you could complete the
square or do some other techniques or
you could try to get into factored form
factored form you can find the zeros and
then you'd know that the x-coordinate of
the vertex is halfway between the
x-coordinate of our two x-intercepts and
then you could figure out the y-value
there but this one is definitely the
easiest
vertex form and what is the vertex
what's going to happen at the point 6
comma 18.
let's do one last example
so this is a different function the
function f is given in three equivalent
forms which form most quickly reveals
the zeros or roots of the function
so once again
when we're talking about zeros or roots
if we have let's say that's the x-axis
and if you have a parabola that looks
like that
the roots are or the zeros are the x
values that make that function equal to
zero or they're the x values of the
x intercepts you could say
and so what x values make or which one
is easy to figure out
when this function is equal to zero
which of these forms because they're all
equivalent you can expand out these
first two and you should get this last
one in standard form
which one is easy to identify the zeros
well in factored form i could just say
well what makes either this thing zero
or that thing zero because an x that
makes this first one zero or the second
one zero is going to make this whole
expression zero so you can quickly say
well if x is equal to negative one this
is going to be zero
or if x is equal to negative 11 this is
going to be zero so this is a very fast
way to find out the zeros
this one here a lot harder you would
have to solve
3 times x plus 6 squared minus 75 is
equal to 0 do some algebraic
manipulation and you would eventually
get to these answers so i would rule the
vertex form right over here
and this forms standard form the first
step i would do is try to get it into
factored form and then from factor form
i would i would find the zeros and so
once again this is definitely more work
than if you already have it in factored
form so factored form is definitely what
you want when you're trying to find the
zeros and here it says write one of the
zeros i could write x equals negative
one or i could have written x equals
negative 11.